good afternoon and good evening
depending on your
location i'm sad omar the director of
the yale institute for global health i'm
really delighted to welcome you to the
global health conversation series
sponsored by and led by the yale
institute for global health and as you
know as a lot of you know already that
the series is a venue
uh for the yale community and beyond uh
to learn from and connect with
uh innovative leaders in global health
uh in addition to
igh
we are grateful for the walker fund by
the macmillan center at yale for
co-sponsoring the series uh including to
today's event uh it's it's a pleasure to
be with all of you today
uh as you know the world faces
unprecedented challenges uh of
humanitarian crises
in more than two dozen countries
resulting from armed conflicts uh
natural disasters uh these are being uh
accelerated and multiplied by the global
climate change
uh and uh and the ongoing covert 19
global pandemic
these emergencies have significant
impact on global health
including increased death illness and
disability
in addition to that the economic cost of
course of these crises are are enormous
so
founded at the call of albert einstein
in
1933 the international rescue committee
uh so i guess no pressure on their
leaders uh to to stand up to this legacy
um
and and so international rescue
committee's mission is to help the
world's most vulnerable people
whose lives and livelihoods have been
shattered
by conflict and disaster including the
climate crisis
and to survive to help them survive
recover and regain control of their
future
and so irc delivers lasting impact by
providing health care
and
engaging in
activities that help children learn and
empower individuals to become
self-reliant in these kinds of
situations
and so so to discuss how we sustain
health and well-being in the face of
disaster
we are pleased to have with us today
david miliband the president and ceo of
iirc uh since 2013 um
mr miliband has overseen the
the agency's operations in 40 crisis
conflict countries and its refugees
resettlement and assistance programs
throughout europe and the americas
prior to joining the irc he has had a
distinguished political career in the uk
uh from 2007 to 2010 for example
he served as the 74th secretary of state
for foreign and
commonwealth affairs uh you know shortly
uh you know in short often referred to
as the uk foreign secretary uh if i'm
not mischaracterizing it um and uh
representing the uk throughout the world
his accomplishments have uh earned him a
reputation in in former president bill
clinton's word
words um as one of the ablest most
creative public servants of our time
um and in 2016 uh
was named one of the world's greatest
leaders by fortune magazine and in 2018
he was inducted to the american academy
of arts and sciences and if those of you
who have gone to that place
it's quite a legacy to be inducted in
the american academy of arts and
sciences uh it has acceptance letters
from charles darwin
uh i think thomas jefferson himself uh
if i if i don't if i'm not
misremembering but at least you know a
few of those uh of of individuals who
have contributed
uh to this country and beyond um
in meaningful ways so he's in good
company there he's an author of of the
book uh rescue refugees and political
crisis of our time
as a son of refugees uh
david if i may uh call you
by your first name brings a personal
commitment to the irc's work and to the
premise of the book that we can rescue
the dignity and hopes of refugees and
displaced people and if we help them in
the process we will risk rescue our own
values welcome david and it's a pleasure
to have you here
thanks very much indeed it's um
really
good to be with you and i'm looking
forward to the
conversation
any questions
wonderful so just to prime the pump and
give you an opportunity to sort of
broadly outline some of the things what
is the scope and scale
of the
humanitarian crises
we are grappling with
around the globe right now
you know as i said the the irc was
founded by albert einstein in 1993. how
does this area era uh compare to other
eras in the history of irc
thanks very much for having me
speak to this distinguished
group and distinguished audience look
we've just published our emergency watch
list for 2022
and this
covers the 20 countries that we think
will be the epicenter of humanitarian
crisis for the year ahead
this the population of these 20
countries is about 800 million people
and in other words 10 of the global
population but these 20 countries
account for
about
80 percent of the people 90 percent of
the people in humanitarian need
including 80 or 90 of the number of
refugees internally displaced civilians
call killed in conflict so in those 20
countries there are about 275 million
people who are in need of humanitarian
aid
led by a country like afghanistan where
22 million people are currently
dependent on the world food programme
for their next meal
and these are countries marked by a
number of factors
many of which are different from before
so obviously
einstein set up the irc in advance of
the second world war
um when we now see that refugees and
humanitarian need is generally we
obviously
all holding our breath about the russia
ukraine situation but generally we're
dealing with wars within states not wars
between states there are actually no hot
wars between states at the moment
pending what happens in
ukraine and
russia there are 55 civil wars going on
so-called civil wars going on at the
moment eight of them classified as
severe because they have more than a
thousand battlefield deaths um
afghanistan as i said uh top of the list
um for the war that's finished
there but um ethiopia yemen uh high on
the
list the second point that's different
from
certainly the origins of the irc
is that
the most likely
consequence of a civil war is a further
war
the duration of conflict is extending
the tools of diplomacy are weak
for
dealing with
civil wars the tools of diplomacy were
developed for
negotiations between states not not for
resolving wars within states and the
duration of displacement of need is
becoming chronic rather than just
acute to use
health
terminology i suppose the third element
that's striking about the
numbers of people in need is that uh
half of them are under the age of 18
two-thirds of them are women and girls
so there's a strong gender dimension to
the
uh structure and geography
of poverty and of humanitarian
needs so i think that's important to
flag
as well now these factors lead us in our
emergency watch list to say that there's
system failure going on states are
failing in their responsibilities to
their own citizens diplomacy is failing
because there are 55 civil wars still
going the legal regime is failing
because
rights to life and livelihood are being
um
circumvented
impunity is the order of the day and the
humanitarian aid system is struggling to
catch up so that's the picture that we
are dealing with that's why we're now a
billion dollar organization with
probably about um 35 37 000 staff
of
employees and day
workers around the world
why we've hired another thousand people
in
afghanistan in the last three months and
just to to round out the picture we're
part of we're a 1 billion organization
in a
40 41 billion sector of the global
economy
which
is called the humanitarian aid sector
and as we may discuss
sits in rather
separate stovepipe from the development
sector where much
global health
provision has made progress in the last
20 years and where
some of the
problems that are most acute um
can be can be
squarely seen in the failure of these
two systems to work with each other so i
hope that gives you a picture
well that that's you know that that's um
that's interesting to say the least the
the the fact that the need is such
uh that that the sector is active and
growing but also the hope
that
um
that there is this um
safety net uh
to mitigate the impact of of the the
system failure that you describe
so getting to a little bit more you know
one of the specific areas of interest
that actually i personally have i work
on vaccines
as part of my sort of a major focus of
work
um
a lot of these situations result in
disruption of immunization efforts
and
you know as i understand irc has worked
with partners
to sort of bridge that gap
in some of these populations so what is
the state of vaccination efforts in
countries where the irc
operates um and and what are some of the
key challenges
uh and what would it take to bridge that
gap
yeah well look there are two parts of
the answer that question i think one is
a
as if we were having this conversation
two years ago and then there's um the
answer in the in the wake of covet so
let me address them separately
um most of the places we work either
have no
effective health system or a very weak
health system sometimes marked by
conflict between the governing
authorities of the places we work and
the national authorities so in the
democratic republic of congo during the
ebola crisis health centers were being
attacked
because they were perceived to be
an imposition
of the central government and the
international
agencies were seen as allies of the
central government in opposition to
local political opposition in the in
eastern kivu
and or in the east of the country and
this raises a very interesting point
that there was really quite spectacular
progress towards the millennium
development goals that were enunciated
in 2000 people talked in 2015 about
being halfway there and the problem is
the second half of the march to
provide global health coverage
is
completely different than the first half
of the march because the first half of
the march was about health system
strengthening whereas the second half of
the march is what you do when
really it's a it's a much more
conflicted situation
and it's very hard to think about a
system there isn't yet a system and
that's where we
um have been working and where we've
tried to break out of the idea that
we're just the quote-unquote emergency
sector that we are
there when people fall down
off a cliff people use this cliche we
should build
this at the top of cliffs not just to
help people in the bottom of the place
um that's wrong
increasingly for the places we work
because there are chronic problems not
just uh disaster of someone falling off
a cliff now the covid crisis has both
fed off those inequalities and
exacerbated those inequalities i mean
the basic answer to your question
what's the vaccine situation in the
places that you work i mean there
basically aren't any vaccines i mean
that's more or less the
situation i mean it's the most stupid
um piece of short-termism on the part of
the global community not to have global
vaccinations i don't need to
have the rhetoric on that i'm sure
you've got the facts to to back it up
but essentially it's the fog of war when
it comes to fighting cobit in the places
that we work but there isn't proper
testing so no one really knows who's got
it
and there isn't proper
um vaccination and in the first year of
the crisis there was very weak
um
public health measures i mean there was
there are information campaigns but
there's a lot of disinformation there
are attempts to promote hand washing
there isn't enough water um
you know the the story uh quite well uh
there's probably an over medicalization
of the idea of health when of course
pandemics
require thought and action beyond the
health sector i'm not sure if i'm
allowed to say that in the
yale
institute of global public health but um
that's the two-part answer that i would
give to your
question i know you're absolutely right
and and one of the things that we do
here at ygh at the university will help
us go beyond the traditional uh
biomedical assets you bring that you
bring to these problems uh because um
you know we know that if global health
solutions uh only
draw from a limited number of fields you
you always almost invariably fall short
and it's not just true for pandemics or
sort of
uh sort of
displaced populations etc it's true for
hiv and
and non-communicable diseases and all of
that stuff so but you're absolutely
right so you alluded to that and you
have previously described that you've
used the term
from the age of
impunity specifically the context of
attacks on healthcare workers etc
and there was like sort of you know
you miss something when you don't have
it
there used to be
maybe
obviously the past looks rosier than it
often is
but but
it doesn't it seem and i think you were
alluding to that that it's more of
um you know direct attacks on health
care workers
at least that perception is there
and and so
um how do we get back to at least what
was there before or
or at least a better
normal in that kind of a situation and
you are uniquely uh positioned
uh because of your political background
in there um and so how do we get back to
that sort of unsaid pact uh between
various players
uh i think first of all we recognize
that the fact that it was unsaid was a
weakness not a strength yeah and
essentially the bargain post 1945 was
that
in parallel or in addition to the rights
of states there'd be rights of
individuals universal human rights and
when i talk about the age of impunity
what i refer to is the abrogation of
those rights
impunity as you know is actions without
consequence crimes without punishment
and when it comes to attacks on health
workers you've got a classic case of
rights to livelihood and civilian
protection in conflict but them being
abrogated by conflict players i mean
syria is the most infamous example
where
attacks on health facilities actually
increased after a u.n security council
resolution
that uh
condemned attacks on health workers and
called for them to cease so you can see
the the impunity in the in the thumbing
of the nose again
in the face of the un
security council resolution obviously
this requires us to think not just about
a humanitarian answer but a political
answer because every
every humanitarian crisis is a political
crisis to every humanitarian emergency
is a political emergency and in the um
launch of our emergency watch list this
year
i talked about the humanitarian sector
but i also ventured into geopolitics to
say that we had a responsibility to bear
witness to what was happening and call
call out
the failure of the international system
to uphold its own norms and then to
suggest ways that they could be upheld
let me just give you one interesting i
think example of this in the interest of
not and i could speak for the next 40
minutes about this so i i i won't so um
at the moment the
veto in the u.n security council which
is held by five
countries
us obviously uk france
china and russia
the the only veto wielding countries
reflecting the balance of power after
1945.
um there is a french proposal
that the veto should be
um suspended in cases of mass atrocity
now that is one way of shifting the dice
a bit
in favor of the civilians who are meant
to be having
protections under the un charter that's
not an answer and it probably won't
happen but it's it's the kind of thing
that would actually shift the balance of
power because at the moment
to state the obvious i suppose impunity
reflects imbalance of power
and you have to have a countervailing
power or galbraith called a
countervailing power to push against
that
now to the extent that shame doesn't
work as countervailing power to the
extent that economic sanction doesn't
work as countervailing power to the
extent that arming opposition groups
which some countries do doesn't work as
countervailing
uh power you need to get to the root of
the imbalance of power which is
essentially the conflict actors think
they've got protection there's a
protection racket for their attacks on
health workers
and that's what i think one has to
understand is the root of this problem
and it needs to be called out and
obviously um the
syrian example
allows those of us in the western world
to to blame the russians and the
iranians and the syrian government but
the yemen example i'm afraid plays the
other way
where
the saudi-led coalition which includes
the us and the uk has it hasn't been
targeting health workers in the same way
but as you probably know 43 kids got
killed in a coached load in northern
yemen
which is also as close to a war crime as
you can
imagine
so there are
those in glass houses have got to be
careful about throwing stones and there
are
i don't want to draw equivalence between
if you like the authoritarian
autocratic parts of the world and the
democratic possibles i think that's a
that's a grievous mistake but i don't
want to seem blind
to the
um
to the failings or to the mistakes that
have been made on quote unquote our side
as well
now that's interesting and and and the
fact that you uh you know you mentioned
this
a political um sort of initiative to
address this
if i can say so
in in our institutions there
you know
my colleagues
can be uh fairly loud
for the right cause
uh so i'm sure you'll find allies uh and
i would love to be loud
there's essentially impunity thrives on
darkness and on quietude and
essentially the 37 70 of
uh victims in war today are of are
civilians not soldiers
yeah no absolutely and so if you if you
need more voices and voices something
that needs to be amplified
amplified by sort of actors and
advocates especially health workers but
not exclusively so feel free to send it
our way and and we would be happy to as
an aside circulation
um and so you know another aspect that
is uh
you know i'm not exaggerating if i would
say that it's a
near existential threat or it's not an
existential threat it is the climate
crisis and actually for vulnerable
communities it is an existential threat
so in your work how have you seen
climate change
affect how conflicts
occur and unfold and not just the the
the number of conflicts but the nature
of conflicts
um and especially going forward
yeah i mean this is an area where it's
easy to be glib but also easy to be
wrong i mean a lot of people talk about
climate refugees
and
that doesn't yet fit the facts i mean
we've got a lot of climate idps
internally displaced people but not that
many people who cross international
borders as a result of climate although
a climate crisis although you can
imagine that happening you asked about
climate and conflict
and
i see this in a couple of ways one is
that obviously the climate crisis
contributes to resource stress and
resource stress is one of the drivers of
conflict so you've got an indirect
um impact
there secondly
there's no question that some of the
people that we serve notably in the
sahel but not only you'll know well that
the
um
there is there is serious scholarship
about how
the climate crisis in northwestern syria
was a contributor to the flow of people
to the cities in 2008 to 2011 and that
contributed to the syrian uprising
um i don't want to opine on that here
but there's no question that
a good number of the communities that we
serve
uh have done very little to contribute
to the climate crisis but are on the
receiving end of its
pernicious effects
and
they move or they are impoverished and
one of the things that we're doing now
is building it we rewrote our strategy a
year ago
a year and a half ago and we now talk
about the climate crisis clearly as a
driver of displacement and a driver of
humanitarian
need
in our watch list of a year ago
not the most recent but the one before
we talked about conflict climate and
covet as the drivers of humanitarian
need and that obviously remains
significantly
the case there's more scholarship to be
done about exactly how that follows
through into
migratory patterns but it's it's obvious
that it's going to be real although to
emphasize i think it's more likely to be
an idp issue an internal displacement
issue of which there are about just so
your audience may not know there's about
35 million refugees and asylum seekers
around the world those are people who've
left their own country
as a result of effectively politics um
as opposed to economics but there's 45
million people who are internally
displaced as a result of conflict and
related issues
um syria being a prime example both of
refugee flows and of idp
flows and obviously
we see we fear we anticipate
the climate crisis as a
as a conflict multiplier if you like
yeah so um
in terms of um
the um
you know
the kinds of things communities can do
around the world like our community here
in new haven
anything specific um
that
communities like new haven can do
our hometown
our host town for this university to
support refugee communities we are
again a center
where a lot of
uh settlement refugee settlement is
happening especially you know including
in the recent crisis
but what are some of the things that
individual communities can do
uh to help out with with these crises
well the irc is a good it's a good
organization to ask that question too
because we work across the arc of crisis
we're an international humanitarian aid
agency but we're also a refugee
resettlement agency in 25 u.s cities
we're the largest refugee resettlement
agency in america and i like to point
out we're actually the number one rated
which is even more important than being
the largest now sadly we're not we don't
we're not allocated the office in
um in new haven and i'm not sure whether
it's catholic charities or the lutheran
world service or highest the hebrew
immigrant aid society that is the
lead agency in
new haven but uh president biden has
said he wants to increase from 15 125
000 the number of refugees
led into america every year this was
before the afghan crisis
he
um
people don't know this but ronald reagan
let him more refugees than any other
american president after the 1980
refugee act was passed under president
carter
um
and i'm afraid president trump ran the
program
almost into the ground down to 12 000
refugees president biden said he would
increase it 145 000 take a year or two
to do that but then we've got the 70 000
afghans who've arrived and there will be
afghans arriving in
new haven just like there will be
congolese or south sudanese or rohingya
from myanmar and what those people need
is the services of resettlement agencies
but they also need buddies they also
need english teachers they also need
people to explain to them how the
american healthcare system
works and
i can say very strongly to you even
though we don't work in new haven it's
not one of the places that we're
allocated by the state department
there's there's a lot for you to do
there i met i'm actually in london at
the moment that's why i've got this
beautiful background that you can see
from this rather spartan hotel room um
but um i was meeting some refugees that
were resettling here in the southeast of
england this morning from afghanistan
and from syria and they need cultural
orientation when you've gone through the
trauma of displacement is a massive
thing
and so you can you can do good locally
as well as using the extraordinary
platform of yale
to reach out globally i mean reaching
out globally we are we are the largest
impact evaluation agency in the
humanitarian sector and we do work with
you we could probably do more
about what works in humanitarian
circumstances we have something called
the outcomes and evidence framework you
can see online which is what our country
directors see so we can do you can do
more through your professional
responsibilities and then as you were
saying earlier there's your voice both
individually and collectively
um because the
the kovid crisis has shown that even
when disaster is staring
um global leaders in the face
they can avoid the responsibility of
attending the global commons and that i
think should be extremely worrying
whether you're in the humanitarian
sector or in the health sector
absolutely so switching gear gears a
little bit you played a
role in the independent panel for
pandemic preparedness and response
actually sort of
it was perfectly involved through my
next-door neighbor ernest visadillo
who's a faculty colleague who's a
faculty member here at yale as well
uh and the
panel prepared a very interesting and
insightful
report uh but this was pre
uh sort of it was around the time that
when the report came out in early 2021
um
it was very uh sort of this was pre
pre-delta
it was around alpha and now omicron and
it was around the time when we had
the hope and somewhat some would say the
the naive illusion that low-income
countries will get the vaccines
fairly quickly so things have changed
since then
um and and so so any thoughts about like
in addition to bearing witness
uh to this enormous tragedy
what are the prospects of some of the
recommendations and you feel free to
highlight any specific recommendations
let me let me let me let me talk about
um
the panel and uh what it said and to
what exactly it's been ignored and then
let me talk also so we're all on the
same page the international panel on
pandemic preparedness response was set
up
by the
world health assembly it was independent
it was chaired by two former prime
ministers helen clark and ellen johnson
sirleaf it had about 15 people who were
who included experts in health but was
not dominated by health experts and the
fundamental insight was that pandemics
are not a health issue they are a health
and security and politics and economic
issue
and the recommendations spoke to that
central point
that
pandemic control required political
leadership at the highest level it
needed additional funding through health
but also non-health institutions it
required a commitment to equity
and that there was a set of structural
recommendations
for the
um world health organization but also
beyond it because
our argument was if everything gets left
to the who it won't get done
because it goes beyond health now what
we got wrong i think or what was a
tactical error
is we our recommendations whether about
ppe or
production facilities or intellectual
property were about future pandemic what
we should have recognized is that what
we need in terms of preparing ourselves
and responding to future pandemics we
actually need now
for the current pandemic and we had
recommendations for the current pandemic
but they were separate from the
recommendations for the future what what
strikes me is that in the we were
published in may 2021 so
um
the uh it's not quite a year but the
health machinery through the world
health organizat health assembly and the
negotiating machinery there
um
doesn't have the political sway to
deliver the money and the
um
political accountability that pandemic
preparedness and response requires and
so we've got a mismatch between
the places that are
um negotiating internationally on this
and the places that have real power now
president biden and his team to be fair
to them
they've held one leader level summit
they're having another one in march to
try to break out of this conundrum that
the the health infrastructure for
negotiation takes years and we haven't
got yours on our side
um but you'll know that the the us is
also quite conflicted about the who
and it's um the wh shows two-thirds
funded by voluntary contributions that's
not a basis for a sustainable
independent
um
independence of mine and that and we
argued very strongly that the who needed
to be more independent and more powerful
to hold countries to account and
um i think it's a real struggle at the
moment hopefully the next summit that
president biden holds will help
address the current crisis and in the
process help prepare us for the next one
because you'll know this better than i
but
my reading suggests we we got lucky with
omicron and it could easily have been
more transmissible than than delta but
also more virulent and
and we've got off in some sense lightly
yeah and there's no guarantee that the
that uh that uh variant that is more
transmissible will have lower virulence
that that seems to be a misconception
that there is some sort of magic
tradeoff that the uh virus makes with
itself that uh
and sort of evolutionary biology has
told us that no that doesn't have to be
the case
um in these kinds of situations um so
i'm now taking one question from the
audience and and the first question
there from there is how do you think
today is change in the liberal world
order as compared to when it was first
established and you can add nuance uh
you know when was the prime of the
liberal world order there was never a
sort of a perfect moment for that
but but let's suppose you know the
current situation has seen changes and
emergence of uh
players that are decidedly illiberal um
in the sort of non-partisan sense of the
word uh and how would that
change humanitarian efforts in public
health
well i think first of all it's really
important that we don't fall into a sort
of golden ageism the cold war was not a
golden age
for obvious
reasons
secondly i do think without wishing to
fall into being panglossian about it
there was a period in the early 2000s it
was a brief shining moment
when ideas of global responsibility
really took uh root it wasn't a product
just at the end of the cold war
it was a product of the frankly the
failings in rwanda and in um former
yugoslavia and that led to this period
where there was a real discussion up
until 2006 about
international responsibilities and
the extent to which state sovereignty
was an insufficient basis on which to
manage an interdependent world order and
i prefer to talk about a rules-based
order rather than a liberal
international order yeah because i think
that um liberal carries too many
is too complicated for for for too many
people i mean you just as a digression
um
that if you remember what i said 20
minutes ago about rights for individuals
that is the essence of a liberal ideal
that individuals have uh have rights but
sometimes when when we talk about
liberal international order we lose side
the fact that it was about rules that
would govern the powerful and try to
protect the powerless
now
how do those
how do the changes that we've seen
affect the question particularly about
health i think there are two things to
say about that
one is back to don't throw stones if
you're in a greenhouse if you're in a
glass house i mean illiberalism i don't
need to tell you the attack on rules
based systems i mean your own i'm i work
in new york i'm but i'm a british
citizen both of our countries have
suffered attacks on on their own rule of
law
recently
and
that is a trend across the
industrialized democratic world
that
um the rules-based order is being poorly
defended
by the world's democratic states which
are a minority of uh states
and
uh certainly a small minority the global
population live in fully democratic
societies and fareed zakaria wrote 20
years ago about
the rise of illiberal democracy so we've
got to tend to our own houses
and actually the just in
parentheses the biden administration's
approach to the
russia ukraine crisis has actually been
an assertion of democratic strength in
the face of an assault on the
rules-based order by a leading
autocratic country
the second thing though is
where and how to combat the assault on
the rules based order from those who
don't want to live by rules at home
in the autocratic world
and here there's a real push and pull
because on the one hand the chinese
leadership fear instability on the other
hand they don't want to have their own
power curved and i think this speaks to
very much
the
uh agenda of the
liberal democratic world the the
democratic world
um standing together in a very clear way
not to invent new rules but to defend
old rules that all countries have signed
because by signing the u.n charter all
countries have signed up to a basic set
of human rights and that has to be
fought over and that's about politics in
the end
i think i think i'm glad that you went
there you went to not just sort of uh
people not playing by the rules uh if
you will at the
inter state level but um you know you
know sort of between states uh in terms
of between state dynamics but also
domestically and and that is uh frankly
something
that varies some of us a little bit more
uh the things that you took for granted
um are under threat
and so but you know extending that
conversation a little bit because there
are actors both state-based and
non-state actors
uh that now have you know in this
interconnected world that has
the power for major disruption uh and as
i understand icrc
uh recently saw um uh you know in terms
of
breach of data uh of uh you know
of vulnerable people and i understand
that coming from a question recently and
you feel free to correct me if this
information is inaccurate uh by a
malicious cyber uh actor
um you know what does the humanitarian
sector need to do uh that's interesting
icrc just so everyone knows is the
international committee on yeah no not
you guys
if you're a donor don't worry we're
we're keeping your stuff safe now let me
just say so the question came for the
broader sector yeah i understand here's
a really interesting point all the
pressure in our sector is to spend less
on quote-unquote administration
but good administration means protecting
data of clients as well as supporters
and you've got to spend on that spending
on cyber security is almost bad spending
in the way some of the charity watchdogs
and others
work on this um any any organization
that says it doesn't spend anything on
administration means it's not spending
anything on cyber security and that
can't be sensible so
you know i could answer the question at
great length but i think just the the
most basic thing to say is
what's the responsibility of the
humanitarian sector it's the
responsibility to tell the truth that
this costs and it's a good investment
yeah no i i agree and so not all
administrative costs are
are created equal sometimes what is
charged at administrative cause
increases the efficiency
of the direct costs of individual
projects and initiatives and i think all
of us need to do a better job uh
including academics uh to communicate
that that this is money you know
um
this money can be very well utilized and
sort of mitigate a lot of substantial
risks and so there's this interesting
question at least i find it interesting
from i think from a postdoctoral fellow
who has a small
there's no way i can cope with it i can
match this brain power
so so so she talks about a small grant
she got to aid the general health of of
god people recently resettled in
oklahoma city
uh and if you had to she's taking an
opportunity to ask you if you had to she
has a small grant
and has a sort of a focused
area
but some flexibility to where to spend
this uh and how to spend this if you had
to pick one health problem to focus on
um obviously difficult as
you know because there is a lot of
things that that you know this is a
difficult question because there are a
lot of things
that are important uh would you go to
the
psychosocial and mental health promotion
or a physical health intervention in a
in an afghan refugee population in this
moment in time in an american city
well i'll tell you we don't actually
work in oklahoma but we work across the
country i'll tell you what i would guess
we would spend it on and then i'll
explain why i use the word guess
i would guess we would decide
to spend it on
mental health because i know that
significant numbers of the afghan
arrivals are deeply traumatized by
their survival and the fact they've left
people behind the reason i say guess is
very important because the right answer
if i may say so to the question is i'd
ask the clients
i mean it's a big part of our approach
that
our needs assessments are not done by
people like me they're done by human
centered designers who are talking to
clients and assessing need and so i hope
that the grant giver who asked this
question obviously i hope they'll give
us the grant but the uh although in
oklahoma i suppose they can't but um the
best answer i think surely is to say
you'd have to ask the people and test
with the people
my instinct is that the proximate need
is more likely to be
greater on the
mental health side than on the physical
health side but i want to cover myself
by saying that's only a guess and i want
to i'd want to really test it with the
population interesting so the next and i
think it's in line with sort of the
ethos of a community-based public health
you you ask the population you do the
work uh
you know using tools like cv power and
others um and so um the next question
actually comes from uh uh the dean of
our school of public health uh here at
yale
um stan vermont and and his question is
that irc is famous very famous for its
reach into
regions of the most acute need
um
and
what are the strategies that you're
using
now
in supporting and rebuilding healthcare
systems
when political systems are very
unsupportive so for example uh you know
syria myanmar or somewhat paralyzed like
like haiti yemen yemen and congo where
the intention perhaps at least a lot of
the intention is there but
the capability is not there because the
public health 101 is
get the buy-in from the government uh
and the government
et cetera but when you don't have that
and sometimes they're antagonistic so
how do you solve
that
conundrum well that we do a health
system strengthening work in in
partnership with local governments or
national governments where they are
willing to work with us
um but in places like north west syria
or elsewhere um the national government
is oppositional and the local
authorities are
non-state
and so
um
we're in a real
we're in exactly the bind the dean of
your school and he's probably got a
better or she's got a better answer than
i have to this but the kind of things i
would talk about are one
um
the information war really matters
and
disinformation and misinformation is the
first enemy of effective public health
and
we are as trusted
partners of local communities we can
work well in tackling misinformation and
disinformation
secondly
um
uh you will know better than i
that a lot of
community-based care can achieve far
more per dollar than health center or
hospital-based care so the second thing
and we've got four research and
innovation priorities one is about
sexual and reproductive health maternal
and newborn health and it's very much
focused on self-care
um we have a second research and
information and innovation priority
around malnutrition
the current system is
for a severe acute malnutrition is
separate from moderate acute
malnutrition and it depends on
people getting to health centers which
in
south sudan they're not going to make it
there
so again you build from the community
level the the
the diagnosis and treatment at a at a
local um level thirdly
an important part of our work now is to
work with non-state partners as well as
state partners community-based
organizations that's an important way of
winning trust but also extending scale
now that doesn't quite count as building
a health system which was the dean's
answer i don't know if he can come on to
the
uh whether you can um mic him up to or
her up uh to say what would be a better
answer because i don't i i'm obviously
far less of an expert than him or her
but
those are the kind of things that we're
trying to do to sustain a web of health
interventions
below the secondary care level which is
frankly not what
where we do the work wonderful so let's
see if if we can uh
uh add sten to the uh panel and if he
can uh he's able to join from that side
um uh you know
one thing that you might want to and i
sort of i wanted to keep that to the end
for the end but i don't want to forget
about it because we have a lot of
questions so you'd love to hear this one
of the comments so it says not a
question but i do want to say thank you
to irc for doing an amazing job
and i thought it's just a blanket uh
appreciation
uh because this person is a former
refugee from rwanda
and with support from irc he was able to
uh they were able to
restart their life here in the us in
2000
and they're now soon to be a student at
yale school of public health wow that's
fantastic isn't that gratifying that's
fantastic really
heartwarming and if if he or she writes
to me
it sends me an email that would be great
i'd love to find out about their story i
mean um
look i think we are we're now the large
i think i've said this the largest uh
impact evaluation agency in the
humanitarian sector and
and that's because we go to places that
people aren't used to studying what
really works but we think it it matters
even more in emergency situations to use
the money well and to use the right
um approaches and um
when when you hear a story like the one
i've you've just said is it
that's really that's really great
wonderful so i got a message that says
uh stan has been promoted and when
faculty hear this news it usually
whether they got tenure or you know
became full professor but sen is already
uh a seasoned public health provider
professionally this this essentially
means that he's here uh on the zoom
panel side so stan do you want to sort
of add to what david said give a better
answer than i would have than i gave
thank you very much i wasn't expecting
to speak but david
your response about the
pivoting from national
partners to local partners and community
partners
i think that is uh very insightful and
really gets to the point that i was
thinking you might make because i've
connected to irc even as a young man
with some of the uh nature of the work
of your organization
and i feel that
when we have circumstances that might
look
to
professionals or donors
or persons of goodwill as almost
hopeless
uh the
rohingya in central myanmar driven from
their homes
um
syria circumstances in
in eastern congo
uh i do think that your answer is
precisely uh what is required one has to
pivot to local
players and stakeholders and see how one
can reinforce
the
circumstances that may be
without
government support or without
long-term sustainability just to
tide uh communities over at a time of
tremendous crisis and stress
so i've seen you do that so i wasn't
surprised by your response and quite the
contrary i thought it was uh
an inspiring response thank you thank
you yeah
and often like sort of and i'm sure
you have the same experience that often
when you work with community
community-based organizations in we weak
states or where the governance systems
governance systems are not that robust
when things stabilize
often it's the manpower from these
community-based organizations and
sometimes not always
it's their legitimization especially if
the resolution is towards the better
state of things um
in these situations um and so again it's
not necessarily bypassing the government
the government it is
uh leveraging what is available
um and often community-based
organizations if i may say is a
mechanism for self-governance that some
communities
use uh to fill in some of the gaps uh
in in in services etc
um and so
there's this interesting but
but provocative if i may say so a
question um around you know what is the
role or approach of the irc in
challenging powers
such as nations with veto powers who are
seemingly immune from sanctions
um and other measures uh that you
mentioned in situations such as the
crisis in yemen but i would say i would
add so the question was around yemen but
i would say there's more than um one
situation
where
you know uh
where this is the case
well look i think our role is always
twofold one is to serve the people
because we have to abide by the
humanitarian principles
of impartiality independence
um and humanity that's very very
important
um neutrality as well
but second i think we have to bear
witness
and we have to speak about what's
actually happening and if there are
allies of the us who are
interfering with humanitarian aid we've
got to say that
now
i'll be absolutely honest with you
without going into specifics there are
places in the world where it's too
dangerous for us to speak out and that
is a real danger in this emergency watch
list that i uh talked about that we
launched for this year and launched in
december in a lecture at the council of
foreign relations i made the case that
we need an independent
office for the protection of
humanitarian access because u.n
officials and ngos
are in double jeopardy if we speak out
we can get kicked out and we need some
independent
leadership and some independent we could
supply the information but then it will
be anonymized so that it could then be
used and but but i think those are our
two responsibilities we've got to serve
the people but we've also got to speak
not for them but we've got to speak to
what we see
and that's what we try to do
i mean we're doing that on afghanistan i
mean we're we're very very very
negative about the current international
economic policy towards the towards
afghanistan even though we're a partner
of the us government
in the u.s and
are happy to partner with them on the
ground
yeah no no i think i think that is the
approach that's how you thread the
needle
um uh
and
so so i have two questions two final
questions the penultimate and the final
questions and related questions one from
a student and the other one from a
faculty member
and you alluded to some part of it but
i'll start with the student question and
you can take them together
the question is many in our audience
aspire to be global health professionals
focused on humanitarian crisis uh
what advice can you share for these um
individuals that could inspire them
the second one is again related uh you
mentioned that you are
the biggest impact evaluator which is
which is very valuable and sometimes
knowing what doesn't work is equally
important as
uh figuring out what works
um
what is you know you know you face a lot
of difficult challenges like this how
does irc and other humanitarian agencies
prepare this uh staff to
face ethical challenges and how do they
partner with universities
in enhancing
uh
some of these
actions and capabilities where
both the partners can benefit uh in
terms of their mission
right i mean on the first i think you
know apply for jobs at the irc i mean
most of the jobs are for local hires in
the places that we work but we we do
have
global hires as well
um but i think the best advice is to is
to get your boots dirty i wish i'd done
that when i was in my twenties and spent
time
internet i mean i spent time at mit that
doesn't count as international um
as international experience really um as
a graduate student um
so i think get your boots dirty um on
the ground
um
making
see
doing research or
seeing what works
um
because i think that's uh that's
invaluable and your 20s is the right
time to do it
from your 20s and your 60s um
in respect to the second question i may
not i'm maybe not going to answer it as
well as i should first of all we have
our own ethical standards boards and we
have to sustain our own ethical
standards that's important
um we don't we don't do randomized
controlled trials of um
denying people some people food and
giving other people food and seeing what
the uh consequences so we have to i mean
maybe that's a
too obvious example but we we we we have
processed to try and adhere to high
standards
i think that my appeal to you would be
that
this really befuddles me i have to
confess to you i know this is a public
event so i'm
maybe i
i'll think how i say this but i'm
completely flummoxed
that a 41 billion dollar sector of the
global economy finds it so difficult to
spend money
on evidence-making it's completely crazy
i mean i thought eight years ago when i
joined the irc that we made outcomes
evidence value for money and innovation
r d our sort of um washing line
or the spine is a better way of putting
of our effort and i thought well it's
obvious if at the time it was 26 billion
i thought well of course if i was a
minister still the first thing i do is
say to the taxpayer well sometimes we
get things right sometimes we get things
wrong but we always put our money behind
what we think works and what we think
works is not just by sticking our finger
in the air it's by doing proper evidence
making and if it then transpires that
the evidence shows it doesn't work well
we were following the evidence and then
it got updated
it's very very hard to raise the money
for evidence-making it's crazy and so um
if you want a good thing to come out of
this um seminar it would be a way for
yale school of public health and us
to to raise a fund to do proper
evidence-making because that's still
short-changed in a completely
short-sighted way
and it it's absurd really for
uh our leadership team to be presented
with the question how much do you put
into evidence-making versus how much you
put into programs
i mean
it's it's a that's a sophie's choice of
really a bad kind and i think that would
be a good thing to come out of this
absolutely data is not distraction um
exactly and and it's it's some of it has
some of the highest return on investment
whenever it is absolutely
it's obvious
so that's great and we'd be happy to
follow up on on on sort of things where
some of the if you give us a bit of the
yale endowment it earmarked some of the
yale endowment for uh annual spend on
evidence-making yeah they absolutely
give me the checkbook there
but now i'm just joking that's what i
was told
yeah so um
no i know i think i think um uh going
forward that that's what
modern global health should look like
and modern a lot of modern global looks
like that and and a lot of uh
modern humanitarian action looks like
that as well
you don't have to withhold interventions
to get at the best practices you can
look at natural experiments as you was
you were alluding to um etc and and sort
of still do robust evaluations and so on
so forth so so on that note uh i want to
thank you
uh for participating in this
conversation series uh hopefully in the
coming years we'll have the privilege to
uh you know have you take uh the train
up to our our little station and and
interact with our students and students
and faculty uh uh
over at break bread with uh with our
community members uh for for a future
event so so so it's been wonderful to
have you here thank you very much uh and
uh and thank you
good night from london thank you very
much good night